So we have seen that hard drives do
not really benefit from Moore's Law. They don't get
much faster and also, although their capacity is
improving, their speed is very, very, very slow. So
one question would be RAMs, especially DRAM, are
benefiting from Moore's Law in terms of capacity. So
their capacity is growing about as fast as
the capacity of hard drives, but they're way faster
than hard drives. Hard drive access times
are about, let's say, ten milliseconds, whereas RAM
access times are well under a microsecond.
So we're talking about at least three orders
of magnitude speed difference. So the reason
we normally do not use memory for storage
is that the hard drives are about
100 times cheaper per gigabyte. However, DRAM has
many times better latency than hard drives. So people came up with this
idea of solid-state disk, SSD, which really is not a disk at all. It is just
solid-state, meaning electronic storage, but because it's
intended as disk replacement they call it
disk. One approach to build a solid-state disk would be to use DRAM and our
controller that will refresh it and then have a battery so that we can keep the
DRAM content refreshed and not lose it. This
is very fast. It's actually very reliable, more reliable
than the hard drives, but it is extremely
expensive. And it is not good for archiving
data because eventually the battery will run out,
and then we lose our content, whereas a hard
drive can be stored for a really long time. Today there is another option, which
is flash memory. So flash is fabricated in
similar technology to the one that is used
for making DRAMs and processors. And it uses
transistors to store data so it benefits from
Moore's law. It consumes very little power because
unlike a disk that spins all the time
even when you're not using it, flash, while
it's idle, consumes very, very little power. And
also it doesn't need to move any heads
or anything. It's still very fast, way faster
than disks, although it is slower than DRAM,
and it has smaller capacity than disks because
for flash we are still expressing their sizes
in gigabytes, whereas disks easily go into the terabytes.
And one good thing about flash, as compared to the DRAM and battery, is that
flash keeps the data alive without power. So you can store something in a flash,
forget about it for several years, and you will probably still be able to read
it, whereas here, your battery will almost
certainly be dry after a couple of years.